[Musique]
les niveaux
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 24 juin de
l'émir poutine partisan d'une reprise du
dialogue avec l'union européenne le
kremlin déclare que le président russe
soutient une proposition franco allemand
qui vise à relancer les contacts directs
entre lieux et moscou au moment où les
vingt-sept sont réunis en sommet à
bruxelles
il sera question des relations avec la
russie avec la turquie de la question
migratoire également des thématiques qui
divise les européens
première visite demain en france dans
tony blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine qui doit rencontrer emmanuel
macron et le chef de la diplomatie
française jean yves le drian un voyage
symbolique pour un francophone et un
francophile qui s'inscrit après la
tournée européenne de joe biden pour
resserrer les liens transatlantiques
outre atlantique le président américain
justement recevra lui à la maison
blanche son homologue afghan ont ce
vendredi au coeur des discussions le
soutien de joe biden en dépit du retrait
de ses troupes d'afghanistan
un retrait qui a démarré le 1er mai et
doit s'achever le 11 septembre prochain
depuis les talibans ne cesse de gagner
du terrain
[Musique]
les sujets de discussion sont nombreux
les points de friction également les 27
dirigeants de lieux se retrouvent en
sommet à bruxelles
pendant deux jours endémie politiques
migratoires européennes relations avec
la russie et la turquie grégoire dont
c'est avec françois xavier lambert
améliorer les relations entre l'union
européenne et la russie
voici l'un des principaux objectifs de
ce sommet à bruxelles
une semaine après la rencontre à genève
entre le président américain et son
homologue russe
les dirigeants de l'ue souhaite discuter
avec vladimir poutine de plusieurs
sujets majeurs qui intéressent les deux
parties la chancelière allemande appelle
à l'unité des européens face à moscou
les événements des derniers mois et pas
seulement en allemagne ont clairement
montré qu'il ne suffit pas de réagir aux
multiples provocations russe de manière
non coordonnée
nous devons créer des mécanismes et
répondre aux provocations ensemble et
unis
ce n'est qu'ainsi que nous pourrons
poser quelque chose aux attaques hybride
de la russie plaide aux réfugiés sera
également discutée entre les 27 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'ue eux
à l'occasion de ce sommet la commission
s'apprête à proposer plusieurs
financements pour les syriens réfugiés
en turquie au liban et en jordanie
c'est une enveloppe de plus de 5
milliards d'euros qui les attendons un
peu plus de la moitié pour ankara qui
pourrait être débloqué de l'argent qui
provient du budget commun auquel
pourrait s'ajouter des contributions des
états membres s'ils le décident
l'un des objectifs de bruxelles ne plus
se contenter d'une aide humanitaire mais
soutenir un véritable développement
socioéconomique d'autres sujets figurent
également à l'ordre du jour à l'occasion
de ce conseil européen
parmi eux le kovy 19 et notamment le
variant delta ainsi que la relance
économique est sur la même ligne 1
tanguay la merkel qu'on a entendu
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé sur la
relation menée avec moscou relais coûte
nous assumons d'avoir un dialogue pour
défendre nos intérêts en tant
qu'européens avec exigence et donc nous
définissons l'unité des européens dans
ce dialogue avec la russie
nous assumons ce dialogue qui est un
dialogue nécessaire à la stabilité de du
continent européen
mais exigeant parce que nous ne sait non
rien de nos valeurs
de nos intérêts et quelques heures plus
tôt de son côté le kremlin a fait savoir
que vladimir poutine était favorable à
la création d'un mécanisme pour un
dialogue et des contacts entre bruxelles
et moscou les précisions de notre
correspondante verhaeghe hoffman la
dîmière poutine soutient une proposition
franco-allemande visant à relancer au
niveau européen les contacts directs
avec la russie et le chef d'état russe a
déclaré le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov
elle a souligné que le président russe
estime que bruxelles et moscou ont
besoin d'un dialogue
je vous propose d'écouter notre
évaluation de cette initiative est
positive le président poutine est
partisan du rétablissement des
mécanismes de dialogue et de contacts
entre bruxelles et moscou le président
poutine l'a dit à maintes reprise
bruxelles et moscou ont effectivement
besoin de ce dialogue
bien évidemment nous suivons de près le
sommet qui a lieu aujourd'hui à
bruxelles et les évaluations de ce
dialogue éventuels qui seront faites là
bas pour le moment aucun préparatif
réelle n'a eu lieu
le fait est que cette initiative a
effectivement été proposé par angela
merkel ensuite soutenu par emmanuel
macron mais la discussion sans de
l'union européenne aura lieu avec la
participation d'autres états membres
c'est pourquoi il est très important de
voir s'ils sont d'accord sur ce point le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov a quant à lui souligné
que le président russe avait des
contacts regus
avec ses homologues français et
allemande pour ce qui est du sommet
union européenne-russie qui lie à pour
lavrov en lien chronologique avec le
sommet poutine byden à genève
écoutez mots au moins une chose est
claire juste l'autre jour l'union
européenne approuve une nouvelle
politique à l'égard de la fédération de
russie qui est formulée comme une
politique reposant sur trois principes
la riposte la dissuasion et
l'implication là où c'est intéressant
pour l'union européenne
cette philosophie est au coeur de
l'initiative du sommet il sera très
intéressant pour moi de voir comment un
tel événement hypothétique évoluera et
donc cela devrait immédiatement être
suivis d'une riposte
et puis ce sera la dissuasion kaka
peuvent sur good shepherd et comment
tout cela va se combiner
c'est encore difficile à dire lors de
son discours devant le bundestag la
chancelière allemande angela merkel a
appelé l'union européenne à un dialogue
direct avec le président russe a pour
elle l'union européenne doit discuter du
format d'un éventuel sommet entre les
dirigeants européens et le président
russe et dans le sillage de la rencontre
entre joe biden et vladimir poutine
l'union européenne est donc en quête
d'une nouvelle stratégie avec la russie
alors les européens doivent-ils repenser
totalement leurs relations avec moscou
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage ce
soir
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes savait qu'à
michael lambert docteur chercheur
associé au fce bonsoir médias lambert
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
michel scarbonchi consultant
international ancien député européen
bonsoir michel scaron qui merci d'être
avec nous les 27 qui débattent donc un
de cette opportunité d'organiser un
sommet entre l'union européenne et le
président russe vladimir poutine
manifestement la rencontre un bail donne
poutine n'a pas laissé les dirigeants
européens différents les a même inspiré
avant de faire réagir je vous propose de
réécouter angela merkel il ne suffit pas
que le président américain parle au
président russe
je m'en félicite vivement mais l'union
européenne doit également créer
différents formats de discussions avec
moscou
nous devons définir un agenda d'intérêt
stratégique commun par exemple dans le
domaine de la protection du climat
mais bien sûr aussi dans les domaines de
la paix et de la sécurité
alors c'est sûr que les thèmes sont
vastes michael lambert qu'elles sont et
les différents dossiers sur lesquels le
dialogue peut se renouer précisément
alors pour ce qui est de renouer un
dialogue je dirais que c'est plutôt
apaisé les tensions la priorité
principale dans la mesure où ces
derniers temps on a vu une augmentation
des tensions entre l'union européenne et
la russie notamment en raison du conflit
dans le haut-karabagh donc avec les
troupes de maintien de la paix russes
qui ont été envoyées détention en raison
de la biélorussie puisqu'il ya eu
l'interception d'un avion est de fait un
blocage aérien de la part des européens
n'est un support de moscou à la
biélorussie ce qui empêche beaucoup de
voyages
vous avez également eu le cas de
l'expulsion des diplomates tchèques des
diplomates russes en tchéquie pardon et
des diplomates russes dans les pays
baltes ainsi qu'en estonie donc tous ces
éléments là sont problématiques dans la
mesure où ça donne l'impression d'avoir
une union européenne qui serait anti
russe ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas
dans la mesure où vous avez des pays et
notamment les grandes puissances
puissance économique l'allemagne mais
également puissance militaire et plus
grand territoire maritime au monde la
france qui eux ne partage pas la vision
des nouveaux membres de l'union
européenne
et c'est ainsi établir un dialogue
entre une russie grande puissance mais
également les grandes puissances de
l'union européenne de manière à pouvoir
avancer ensemble et à des désenclaver un
petit peu cette situation dans la mesure
où pour l'allemagne c'est essentiel pour
pouvoir justifier son projet nord stream
2 et pour la france c'est essentiel pour
avoir un allié solide la russie
notamment pour les projets
internationaux puisque là on parle de
grande puissance donc france et russie
alors la rencontre poutine by day c'est
ce qu'elle a déclenché un déclic pour
les européens en tout cas il ya eu
clairement une réflexion avant nous
faire réagir
monsieur oscar bon qui est écouté ce
commentaire d'un diplomate européen qui
s'est exprimé de façon anonyme dans la
presse belge
l'ue doit avoir la même approche que les
états unis personne ne critique joe
biden quand il rencontre vladimir
poutine il est important de dialoguer
avec les personnes avec qui on n'a pas
le même point de vue alors ça y est les
européens décident de regarder les
choses en face la russie doit être un
partenaire est pas un ennemi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on le réalise maintenant tout
d'un coup alors l'europe michel
scarbonchi n est il pas temps de mettre
fin à la guerre froide depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale est terminée
depuis 76 ans et nous sommes toujours au
coeur de la guerre froide nous les
européens en première ligne joe biden
est venu demander le soutien des
européens contre la chine et je crois
que le président français et la
chancelière allemande lui ont dit que il
était probablement d'accord face à la
chine mais que sur le continent européen
il fallait leur laisser la main face à
la russie
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que tout
simplement nous devons enfin discuter
entre l'union européenne et la russie
c'est ça paraît absurde inconcevable
qu'on en soit à se poser cette question
1 mais il est temps il est temps et il
est temps d'arriver à quoi il est temps
d'arriver à un accord sur la sécurité
européenne avec la garantie des
frontières actuelles en échange d'une 2
d'une politique économique et financière
à l'égard de la russie
on doive on doit mettre en place dans
les prochains mois un pacte d'intérêt
mutuel
il faut ramener la russie dans le camp
européen alors qu'elle a tendance
naturellement du fait de la politique
des sanctions américaines européennes à
aller de plus en plus vers la chine donc
il est absurde que l'on que l'on
n'arrive pas à ramener les rues ce prix
nous nous appartenons au même continent
nous avons pratiquement la même histoire
là alors certains diront pas les mêmes
valeurs mais des valeurs communes en
tout cas qu'est ce qui nous différencie
le niveau de nos démocraties
le stade de nos démocraties voilà bah il
faut en parler
donc je pense que dans les prochains
mois il faudra la présidence française
monsieur macron va s'y employer je pense
à la tête de l'union européenne il
faudra créer une stratégie et réunir les
27 ce qui n'est pas facile parce que les
états baltes la pologne la suède sont
vent debout face à la russie bon alors
l'histoire peut expliquer cette position
mais bon nous ne sommes plus en 1940
nous sommes en 2021 donc il faut arriver
à convaincre les 27 d'avoir une
politique commune face à la russie et de
faire confiance à l'allemagne à la
france pour en engager un processus de
discussions de dialogue de négociation
et on arrivera à mettre en place des
intérêts communs nous avons été ses
intérêts de la russie
la russie vit très mal les sanctions
qu'elle subit nous n'avons aucun intérêt
à la boue vrir nous savons très bien que
quand on a pro vie en appauvri une
grande puissance ça conduit toujours à
la guerre donc il est hors de revenir
sur un chemin intelligent et je crois
que le président français la chancelière
allemande lanfains compris à eux de
convaincre leurs partenaires européens
de choisir ce chemin là et au président
français d'organiser au premier semestre
un sommet union européenne-russie en
tout cas le kremlin a réagi positivement
cette proposition on l'a vu michael
lambert ce serait une entente gagnante
gagnante quels sont les intérêts des uns
et des autres à ce réchauffement des
relations bien le dire est qu'il ya
plusieurs éléments à prendre en compte
de pays à pays est également d' union
européenne et russie de pays à pays
comme on l'a mentionné la transition
énergétique en allemagne notamment avec
l'arrêt des centrales nucléaires amène à
la problématique de nord stream 2 et à
partir de là la nécessité d'avoir plus
de gaz russe qui vient en allemagne on
ne peut pas avoir une politique en
allemagne où d'un côté on clame la
russie et à côté de ça on demande à
avoir plus de gaz importé donc il faut
diminuer ces tensions pour pouvoir
ensuite accentué les relations
économiques pour la france il s'agit de
coopérer avec une grande puissance sur
des dossiers internationaux d'éviter
effectivement que la russie se tourner
exclusivement vers la chine ce qui n'est
dans l'intérêt de personne dans la
mesure où la russie a un intérêt à être
avec l'europe et à être dans une
position entre 2 et ne pas la pousser
exclusivement vers vers la chine
effectivement un autre élément à prendre
en compte et ça ça viendra peut-être
dans les mois à venir c'est que les
tensions avec la biélorussie amène à des
questions géopolitiques beaucoup plus
profonde
tout comme l'a été le cas en syrie
justement on le remarque notamment avec
la biélorussie une biélorussie qui est
plus proche du kremlin
ça signifie une biélorussie qui a sa
politique alignée sur celle du kremlin
et se pose dès lors la question de la
reconnaissance de l'abkhazie par la
biélorussie ce qu'a fait la styrie en
et ça pousse justement cette question de
comment est-ce qu'on peut nouer un
dialogue de manière à éviter d'avoir des
positions géopolitiques qui sont
antagonistes
donc en fait ce qu'est cette question de
la phrase i va revenir d'une manière
assez étonnante dans les mois à venir
tout comme elle est venue dans le cas de
la syrie et ça c'est un élément
fondamental notamment pour les services
de renseignement mais c'est ce que tout
le monde attend en fait en toile de fond
après il ya effectivement cette question
d'éviter également d'avoir deux union
européenne donc une union européenne de
l'est qui serait avec les pays baltes ou
encore avec la pologne et la tchéquie
anti russe est une union européenne de
l'ouest qui serait vraiment celle des
grandes puissances
et conduire sur le chemin justement
michel scarbonchi de ces deux europes
l'est les pro russe et et si j'ose dire
les anti russe c'est le chemin
clairement on est en train de prendre en
europe
oui tout à fait l'union européenne a
déjà défini un certain nombre de
secteurs sur lequel il est prêt à
débattre avec la russie sur le climat
sur l'environnement sur la santé sur
l'énergie sur le terrorisme on doit y
ajouter le problème des frontières
on doit y ajouter le problème de la
dette des cyber attaques
la russie doit cesser ce genre de
politique
moi j'étais très malheureux lorsque
monsieur poutine et monsieur lavrov
croyant bien faire on est humilié joseph
bourrel le ministère étrangers européens
qui étaient venus en éclaireurs pour
préparer le terrain un dialogue union
européenne russie est qui et qui hélas
pris au piège à moscou et humilié aa n'a
servi qu'à être content contre-productif
c'est-à-dire à braquer les européens
encore plus contre la russie voilà et
donc il faut que des deux côtés on y met
du sien
monsieur poutine s'il est pris à un
sommet acquise européen parce que c'est
son intérêt sans intérêt économique et
son intérêt politique à long terme je
pense que on va on va évoluer
positivement dans les prochaines
semaines et dans les prochains mois et
en même temps c'est on vit avec cette
chape de plomb de la guerre froide on se
rend pas compte parce que dans la vie de
tous les jours on parle pas que de ça
donc mais nous vivons avec le risque
nucléaire le risque de conflit en un
sens on a eu des conflits larvés au
donbass en syrie et ceram et donc les
des européens vivent avec st donc il est
temps de tourner cette page là cette
page noire de nos relations pour engager
une nouvelle page qu'il faut écrire et
moi je fais confiance au président
macron inquiet qui depuis longtemps
conseiller en cela par monsieur
l'ancien ministre socialiste français
jean pierre chevènement a toujours été
pour un rapprochement avec la russie
on en revient à la thématique gaullienne
un d'une europe qui va de du portugal
jusqu'à la sibérie et donc d'une europe
puissance alors il appartient à l'union
européenne de devenir elle-même une
puissance pour devenir une puissance
elle doit être capables de parler d'égal
à égal avec la russie et donc elle doit
se donner les moyens d'être unis d'abord
face à la russie ensuite de créer les
conditions de ce que j'appelais impact
d'intérêt mutuel et je crois qu'on y
arrivera la volonté existe donc le
chemin à l'envers quand on entend
effectivement josep borrell qui se dit
humiliée ont repris effectivement par
michel scarbonchi savon qui c'est votre
analyse aussi parce que bon c'est vrai
que la russie leur chien bashing c'est
aussi dans l'autre on s'en est bien
placé pour le savoir
ici quand même je dirais que c'est
toujours une partie de ping pong c'est
comme ça que j'ai mal à décrire c'est à
dire que quand vous avez détention d'un
côté il ya une réponse de l'autre côté
donc vous humilier quelqu'un vous avez
une réponse
les russes ne sont pas les premiers à
vouloir justement mettre la pression sur
quelqu'un ou à humilier quelqu'un c'est
souvent en réponse à partir de là je
dirais que si on dialogue d'égal à égal
vous avez un dialogue entre grandes
puissances mais également un dialogue
honnête entre des grands pays qui ont
beaucoup à partager et qui ont déjà
beaucoup partagé de par le passé donc je
veux faire cette idée effectivement que
il ya une réponse à une action qui a été
fait mais vous n'avez pas d'une manière
farfelue on va dire quelque chose de
violent
c'est mon analyse donc il faut
simplement traiter les partenaires
d'égal à égal avec respect merci
beaucoup en tout cas michael lambert
michel stern banquier d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france pour ce
décryptage
si vous est alors que l'europe à débat
également durant ce sommet du
renouvellement du pacte migratoire
conclu en 2016 avec la turquie amnesty
international a publié un rapport
accablant pour le gouvernement grec
témoignages à l'appui le ng montre
comment violence et renvois forcés vers
la turquie sont systématisées
accusations dont athènes se défend les
détails en images
[Musique]
oui
les renvois forcés illégaux opérés dans
la violence constitue désormais de fait
la politique grecque de contrôle des
frontières dans la région de l'evros
[Musique]
et autre sujet de débat lors de ce
sommet européen la nouvelle loi
hongroise accusé de discriminer des
personnes lgbt elle doit entrer en
vigueur le 1er juillet le texte prévoit
que la pornographie et les contenus qui
représente la sexualité ou promeuvent la
déviation de l'identité de genre le
changement de sexe et l'homosexualité ne
doivent pas être accessible aux moins de
18 ans fin de citation la loi ne porte
pas sur les homosexuels elle concerne la
façon dont les parents veulent faire
l'éducation sexuelle de leurs enfants
s'est défendu le premier ministre
hongrois viktor orban la majorité en
tous cas des pays de l'ue elle appelle à
revoir son texte le premier ministre né
à lons et propose même lui une mesure
radicale à l'encontre de nature de la
hongrie pour moi avec cette loi il ne
plus rien à faire dans l'union
européenne mais je ne suis pas seul à
décider
il y avait 26 autres pays cela doit se
faire étape par étape
l'ambassadrice britannique a été
convoqué au ministère des affaires
étrangères russe la russie est réclame
l'ouverture d'une enquête après la
traversée d'un navire britannique dans
ses eaux territoriales
comme en témoignent ces images du
ministère russe de la défense
pierre des avions de chasse de l'armée
russe ont volé à proximité du death
trailleurs de la royal navy dans le but
de le faire changer de route
si pour d'autres boris johnson sa
traversée légitime pour les autorités
russes l'utilisation de cette voie
maritime proche du littoral de la crimée
s'apparente à une provocation
à mon sens l'utilisation des eaux
internationales est entièrement légitime
est d'ailleurs un autre point important
est que nous ne reconnaissons pas
l'annexion de la crimée par la russie et
ses eaux font partie du territoire
ukrainien
cette voie maritime est légal et nous
sommes libres de l'emprunter d'autant
plus si ces larges la plus rapide et
c'est ce que nous avons fait ce qui est
de tester notre défi sens prêt
on risque la royale mais vite renommée
sur ma vie à 10 heures plus tôt que
défenseur je pense que ce n'est sur le
plus approprié vous poussant les
agresseurs restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
première visite demain en france dont
tony blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine doit rencontrer manuel macro
un voyage symbolique pour un francophone
et un francophile qui s'inscrit après la
tournée européenne de joe biden pour
resserrer les liens transatlantiques
et puis nous parlerons du président
américain qui lui recevra demain à la
maison blanche son homologue afghan
rester avec nous
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de 10,6 pc et écrans de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise ces firmes
mais comment peuvent-ils mentir comme
des arracheurs de dents ce point
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï pj les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir amitié
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays d'afrique
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti covit
périmés il faut craindre une vaccination
low cost en afrique lors une vaccination
reste une vaccination savez la
vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent
où est le mécanisme de la vaccination
vous savez ça a soulevé beaucoup
d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
bacs cela c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud beaucoup de pays ont
cette admission l'avoir amené l'agenda
de la santé publique au top des
priorités c'est quelque chose que nous
saluons énormément au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
il ne cesse d'augmenter et devrait
atteindre cette année 9 4% du pib
français
un record on parle bien sûr du déficit
public quand vous avez un déficit de
près de 10% et que vous allez faire
peut-être aux quatre peut-être 5% de
croissance
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant eh bien
vous êtes en récession de 6 quoi en gros
c'est ça que ça veut dire mais plutôt
dans une stratégie de deux dirigeants
lahlou 15 après moi le déluge
mais le déluge s'il va finir par arriver
si l'on continue à avoir ce type de
désinvolture et d'insouciance vis-à-vis
de la situation de nos finances
publiques qui a beaucoup d'activités qui
sont plus habiles bras et qui le jour où
il n'y a plus de lignes à plus d' aides
vont s'effondrer
on continue à espérer et dans
l'efficacité d'un plan de relance qui
est totalement inappropriée et
totalement perpendiculaires aux besoins
de l'économie française
[Musique]
20h30 souhaité bienvenue en direct sur
arte france si vous nous rejoignez la
tournée européenne dont tony blinken
chef de la diplomatie américaine se
poursuit
il rencontrera ce vendredi le président
français à l'elysée avec un objectif
s'entendre sur mines diplomatique entre
alliés historiques un sujet signé
grégoire dos et renforcer les liens avec
ses partenaires transatlantiques
les intentions de l'administration biden
sont clairs et les multiples rendez vous
sur le vieux continent du président
américain et de son secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken ce mois ci en sont
l'illustration
en visite dans la capitale allemande ce
mercredi à l'occasion d'un sommet
international sur la libye
blinken a rencontré la chancelière
angela merkel et il n'a pas lésiné sur
les compliments pour décrire la relation
entre berlin et washington
je pense qu'il est juste de dire que les
états unis n'ont pas de meilleur
partenaire pas de meilleur ami dans le
monde que l'allemagne
et cela commence bien sûr par des
valeurs et des intérêts partagés mais
aussi je pense par quelque chose que la
chancelière a exprimé une conviction
partagée que de tous les défis auxquels
nous sommes confrontés et qui ont un
impact sur la vie de notre peuple nous
savons et nous convenons qu'aucun pays
ne peut y faire face nous nous appuyons
sur une longue histoire de bonnes
relations germano américaines et nous
sommes heureux que les états unis pour
citer joe biden soit de retour sur la
scène multilatéral l'allemagne et
l'amérique sont des partenaires dans ce
contexte et nous connaissons notre
responsabilité et je me réjouis de cette
conversation
c'est désormais sur le sol français que
le chef de la diplomatie américaine a
posé le pied ce jeudi soir un pays qu'il
connaît bien pour y avoir vécu pendant
sa jeunesse une période d qui lui a
permis entre autres d'apprendre à parler
un français parfait mais si paris reste
un partenaire privilégié de la maison
blanche
emmanuel macron entend bien faire en
sorte que l'union européenne garde une
certaine indépendance vis-à-vis de
washington sur les grands dossiers
internationaux
je me félicite du réengagement américain
dans le concert des nations
et dans cette ce multi latérale isme
coopératif est pour moi la clé c'est que
les européens restent unis et attentifs
à leur souveraineté commune et c'est que
nous puissions avoir aussi une autre
voie communauté de valeurs mais
indépendance quand il s'agit de notre
stratégie à l'égard de la chine
stratégie à l'égard de nos voisins qu'il
s'agisse de la russie ou de la turquie
responsabilités quand il s'agit de gérer
nos voisinages les balkans la
méditerranée le continent africain une
position française qui nuance quelque
peu la posture allemande et qui pose la
question de la convergence diplomatique
entre paris et berlin
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
bonsoir et mme hélène dupuy merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
anthony blinken juste après un job
hayden cette tournée européenne est ce
qu'elle montre que le nouveau président
veut à tout prix renouer les liens forts
avec ses alliés européens
oui mais on comme le vôtre reportage
montre parfaitement il vient quand même
néanmoins une à différentes approches
entre la france et l'allemagne
en ce qui concerne la relation avec les
états unis et il ya aussi une volonté
pour le président aimait raconte de se
réapproprier des dossiers en matière de
politique étrangère qu'ils ont un petit
peu éloigné de la scène précisément
puisqu'il n'avait pas pu rencontrer ses
homologues il a rencontré la nuit là il
a pu bénéficier pardon du premier dîner
en présentiel comme on dit désormais
avec la chancelière merkel là
errance de berlin qui s'est tenue il ya
quelques heures a bien montré aussi que
la position française est unie et
peut-être qu elles divergent un peu des
positions américaines en tout cas il y a
une volonté de la part de la france de
dire qu'évidemment elle se réjouit du
multilatéralisme actifs ou coopératif
comme le gmail mâcon mais qui a sans
doute peut-être des dossiers sur lequel
il ya des lignes un peu plus divergentes
lequel ne sont tolérés alors
effectivement depuis berlin anthony
blinken a ainsi martelé que les états
unis n'avaient pas je cite deux
meilleurs amis dans le monde que
l'allemagne rien que ça paris appréciera
ça dit quoi précisément cette
déclaration on parlait de points de
convergence avec l'allemagne y en a
tellement qui diffère avec heures la
france lassée du tout c'est évidemment
ce que ça veut dire c'est que la
puissance économique du monde est
supérieure à la puissance économique
française et que la mobilisation des
etats-unis vis-à-vis du continent
européen et davantage économique année
stratégique
les premières visites du président bas
et elles n'ont pas été pour l'europe
mais je présente à égal et du ministre
de la défense ainsi que du secrétaire
d'état l'ont été pour l'asie et que le
regard que les états unis ont vis-à-vis
de l'europe c'est avant tout un marché
c'est un marché pour ces compagnies et
de ce point de vue les états unis ont
disons diplomatiquement regarder avec un
peu de préoccupations la manière dont
les européens entendent eux taxés leur
big tech donc la principale entreprise
du numérique mais en même temps quelle
quand il évoque que le fait que
l'allemagne est le meilleur allié des
états unis a en tête bien sûr le fait
que l'allemagne a aussi un autre allié
économique dans son voisinage immédiat
qu'est la russie
nasri les deux étant peut-être la ligne
de faille ou la ligne de fuite sur
lequel les américains entendent ré
engager un dialogue avec la russie avait
parlant avec la
les etats-unis n'ont pas pu empêcher en
galets merkel de terminer les quelques
170 km qui reste du de cet oléoduc
mais on voit bien que les américains
souhaitent aussi réengager le dialogue
avec l'allemagne sur un plan économique
et peut-être plus symboliquement avec la
france dans les espaces qui constitue sa
profondeur stratégique la méditerranée
l'afrique est bien évidemment parmi
cette zone le sahel alors en même temps
on souligne évidemment comment ne pas le
souligner que anthony blinken est un
francophone et francophile il a même
grandi fait ses études à paris ça va
forcément peser d'ailleurs jean yves le
drian et anthony blinken se connaissent
déjà très bien
oui alors je suis pas tout à fait
totalement d'accord avec 7 7 7
cette version des choses évidemment tony
blinken a passé ses humanités partie des
humanités comme on dit en france ça ne
veut pas forcément dire que la totalité
de la diplomatie américaine et
francophile et encore moins francophones
ensuite la position américaine est une
position vis-à-vis de la france qui est
un petit peu celle que récuse et le
général de gaulle
c'est à dire l alignement ou du moins
une proximité qui fait qui fait que les
la francophonie rejoint la francophilie
quand l'argentin diplomatique des
partenaires est totalement alignée à
celui des américains je ne suis pas tout
à fait certain que vis-à-vis de la
turquie ce soit le cas je suis encore
moins convaincu que ce soit le cas sur
d'autres dossiers notamment la
reconstruction en syrie où il est
vraisemblable que les états unis
entendent dialoguer avec leurs autres
partenaires la turquie qui est pas
forcément le nôtre donc la francophilie
et la francophonie du secrétaire d'état
est une avancée mais je ne suis pas
certain que hélas le passé nous le
prouve que la leur aux pénalités si
j'ose m'exprimer ainsi d'un certain
nombre de secrétaires d'état avant et
était consubstantielle d'une politique
étrangère plus conciliante vis-à-vis de
la france où vis-à-vis de l'europe les
etats-unis ont été très clair lors du g7
de carves b il ya de cela deux semaines
bien sûr que un certain nombre de
sanctions qui ont été mises en avant par
le président donne un train vis-à-vis de
l'aluminium taxation à 25% de la sle a
dit pardon glaciaire % de l'aluminium à
10% et est un très mauvais signal par
rapport à cette amitié je suis pas du
tout certain que la concurrence très
vigilant tout très ferme très active
entre boeing et airbus même si on n'a
évidemment pu obtenir un accord
s'arrêtera du jour au lendemain parce
que le secrétaire d'état américain a
fait ses études à paris alors autre
dossier un dense on n'a pas encore parlé
ensemble le dossier chinois l'objectif
est évidemment de montrer un front uni
contre la chine l'objectif américain
sauf que là aussi il ya quelques petites
divergences sur la manière
d'entreprendre la chine emmanuel macron
qui aimait des réserves face à la
manière de se confronter avec pétain et
notamment l'utilisation de l'otan à ses
formes n'est ce pas là pour le coup
c'est une convergence européenne les
jeunes sont élevées jusqu'à général de
l'otan a été très clair
l'otan n'a pas été créée et n'est
absolument pas l'objectif de contenir la
chine s'il faillit trouver une
légitimité à l'otan c'est évidemment le
contexte de l'union soviétique peut-être
un peu moins de la russie mais ça reste
évidemment un débat interne à
l'organisation en tout cas là il ya une
vraie divergence par rapport à la
manière dont les états unis veulent
s'engager dans une confrontation binaire
confrontés à des contrôles de lire une
confrontation pardon direct vis-à-vis de
la chine
évidemment les états unis souhaitent
avoir des partenaires en dans la zone
indo pacifique où évidemment là où la
confrontation et géographiquement la
plus évidente ou en tout cas là la moins
évitable c'est à dire dans le nord-est
de l'océan pacifique
mais je ne suis pas du tout certain que
ce soit à l'otan de 10 procédé je suis
encore moins certain que à force de
diluer les responsabilités de l'otan qui
est avant tout une agression de sécurité
collective et non pas une association un
peu fourre tout dans lequel le président
américain voudrait y mettre où il
remettre une sorte d'agent d'un des
démocraties occidentales
là-dessus la france je crois divergent
un peu sur l'idée que ce ne serait que
des démocraties occidentales qui
pourrait brider ou vider le monde vers
cette aspiration que le président joe
biden a lui-même évoqué dans un article
qui est paru dans le washington post il
ya trois semaines
je suis absolument convaincu que là il
ya sans doute une exigence de la part
des diplomaties française et qui je
crois est une et conductrices depuis
quelques mois du président français
merci de rester avec nous si vous le
voulez bien manuel du puisqu'on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour
évoquer une autre actualité puisque si
anthony blinken est à paris joe biden
lui reçoit ashraf ghani le président
afghan demain à la maison blanche
au menu le soutien des états unis en
dépit du retrait de leurs troupes
d'afghanistan
un retrait qui a démarré le 1er mai et
qui doit s'achever le 11 septembre
prochain depuis les talibans ne cesse de
gagner du terrain alors que les
ministres milices afghanes se forme afin
d' assurer elles mêmes la sécurité des
habitants
emilie ghoga
une démonstration de force directement
adressé aux talibans en tenue militaire
armée drapeau afghan à la main une
centaine d'hommes défilé ce mercredi
pour mettre en garde ceux qui menacent
la paix en afghanistan mais aussi pour
afficher leur soutien aux forces de
sécurité du pays
nous avons organisé ce rassemblement
pour informer les talibans qu'ils
devraient être vigilants et qu'ils ne
pourront jamais nous faire de mal ou
brûlé nos maisons comme par le passé
nous sommes prêts à nous défendre tant
que nous serons en vie et nous ne
laisserons jamais les talibans prendre
notre pays
tuez nos jeunes ou boulet nos écoles
nous sommes prêts à tout type de
sacrifices nous sommes ici pour
mobiliser la milice locale tard les
talibans et les insurgés pakistanais
provoque des affrontements et des
troubles dans notre pays ils tuent des
gens
nous sommes donc là pour lutter contre
eux et les combattre jusqu'à ce qu'ils
soient anéantis des milices armées
formée dès le mois d'avril à l'appel de
zoulficar omid un leader hasard à une
minorité chiite particulièrement ciblés
par les talibans et des shs d'autres
groupes ethniques ont également décidé
de s'armer une nouvelle ligne de défense
alors que le retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan a commencé le
1er mai depuis les talibans ne cesse de
gagner du terrain
une avancée qui inquiète les nations
unies d'après la représentante spéciale
de l'onu à kaboul
plus de 50 des trois cent soixante dix
districts afghans sont tombés entre les
mains des talibans la poursuite par les
talibans de cette campagne militaire
intensive serait une ligne de conduite
tragique
elle conduirait à une violence accrue et
prolongée qui aggraverait les
souffrances du peuple afghan et
menacerait de détruire une grande partie
de ce qui a été construit et durement
gagnés au cours des vingt dernières
le conflit pourrait s'étendre à d'autres
pays de la région
mardi les talibans ont pris le contrôle
de sheer khan
le poste frontière le plus important
avec le tadjikistan
depuis les talibans contrôlent la
principale route d'accès aux pays
voisins
un axe stratégique pour les échanges
économiques avec le reste de l'asie
centrale
selon des sources sur place sheer khan
serait tombé en seulement une heure et
on retrouve donc emmanuel dupuis pour en
parler un président le rappelle a
destitué prospective et sécurité en
europe
emmanuel dupuis clairement quel est
l'objectif de cette visite déjà pour le
président afghan dire adieu sans doute
le président afghan a été pris sous
pression d'accepter des élections
législatives anticipées puisqu'il a été
élu en septembre 2019 souvenons nous que
quand il y en avait écrit une lettre à
ses comminatoire en disant que c'était
la seule solution pour que les talibans
reviennent à la table des négociations
ce qu'ils ont fait nonobstant les
attaques incessantes qui se sont suivies
le président achats frannie rencontre le
président américain alors même qu'une
délégation américaine se rend en turquie
pour rencontrer leurs homologues turcs
on voit bien que les américains qui ont
accepté de partir sans condition et qui
ont engagé leur rapatriement de leurs
troupes déjà très engagée puisque votre
reportage mentionne québec que ce
rapatriement a commencé le 1er mai date
symbolique que le président donald trump
voulait utiliser comme la fin de la
présence américaine en afghanistan mais
ce déploiement est très très engagée
puisque près de 50% des 3500 américains
sont déjà partis d'afghanistan
donc on voit bien que les leviers de
l'afghanistan est en train de sombrer
dans une certitude de d'instabilité le
chef d'état major américain mc miley
dans une audition devant le congrès a
été encore plus incisif et peut-être
encore plus pessimiste que la
représentante spéciale d'abord un
l'alliance du secrétaire général des
nations unies 7 représente cette
diplomate américaine mentionnait que 51
des 4 119 districts étaient tombés le
chalutage a rappelé qu'un est beaucoup
plus précis ils éventrent le chiffre de
90 district et bien évidemment en
résonance ou en écho avec un rapport
d'un des services de renseignement
américains nommément de l' agence de
renseignement du ministère de la défense
qui précise que au mieux le gouvernement
afghan résistera six mois avant que les
talibans reprennent le pouvoir donc en
gros après vingt ans de présence
américaine 2400 militaires américains
tués près de 3 trillions de dollars
dépensés on revient à une situation qui
ressemble à la prise de pouvoir des
athlètes des talibans en 1996
ça veut dire que c'est retour à la case
départ tout ça pour ça on voit que
l'armée afghane et les ministres et cei
2ce s'autoformer pour pour tenir alors
certes
washington a promis de continuer à
soutenir le gouvernement afghan une aide
diplomatique économique et humanitaire
mais mais c'est vrai que ça paraît vain
alors sa part et d'autre en vain que les
talibans ont une stratégie votre partage
le mentionne la prise de la ville
frontière avec le tadjikistan est
beaucoup plus que symbolique galles est
stratégique ça permet de bloquer ou de
fortement limité le rapatriement des
matériels militaires américains qui
n'ont pas beaucoup d' échappatoire soit
par le pakistan soit par l'ouzbékistan
ne soit pas le tadjikistan il se trouve
qu'une déroute est désormais sous le
contrôle des insurgés est plus sous le
contrôle étatique
cela évidemment va un peu perturbé la
manière dont les américains vont se
redéployer
et puis évidemment il ya la stratégie
qui consiste à ne pas rentrer dans les
villes ou dans les principales villes
est à peu près une trentaine précisément
34 métropole capitales provinciales
afghanes les talibans estiment qu'elles
n'ont pas besoin de rentrer dans ses
dents c'est dans ces villes
premièrement parce que c'est là que se
trouvent les principales garnisons
singulièrement une partie des troupes
étrangères
au delà des 3500 militaires américains
les 7000 de l'opération les lots de ce
corps donc l'opération italienne
les talibans savent très bien qu'une
fois que les américains seront partis et
que dans la foulée les différents
contingents allemands italiens espagnols
auront également quitter le territoire
l'armée afghanes comme ça a été le cas
dans le poste frontière déchire cannes
comme ça a été mentionné mettront à plus
d'une heure pour quitter les le poste c
est la durée qu'a duré entre guillemets
l'offensive des talibans contre la ville
frontière on comprend que les talibans
vous venez nous l'expliqué sont très
organisés et rencontres certain succès
au moins ce que certains plutôt actif
droite ton ce succès
par exemple en termes de financement qui
soutient logistiquement les talibans
évidemment c'est pakistan et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la pression jusqu'à
présent n'a pas été suffisamment forte
vis-à-vis du voisinage pakistanais si on
peut trouver un avantage à la politique
afghane du président donald trump s'est
évidemment d'avoir mis davantage de
pression que ses prédécesseurs vis-à-vis
du puissant voisin
évidemment qui partagent une frontière
mais évidemment qui est une base arrière
pour un certain nombre d'heures
d'insurgés il existe un mouvement
taliban au pakistan et bien évidemment
les talibans afghans trouvent refuge
armements et trouver formation dans le
pays voisin
mais il n'ya pas que le pakistan il y a
aussi des intérêts étrangers dans ce
contexte où dans ce conflit votre
pointage mancienne un certain nombre de
milices qui sont en train de se créer
une bonne partie de ses ministres sont
liées à des communautés des communes
était ouzbèke
la commune était tadjik la communauté
hazara donc déchi donc
traditionnellement plus proche de l'iran
on a le sentiment que malgré nonobstant
la présence forte près de cent cinquante
mille hommes au plus fort de
l'intervention militaire occidentale
près d'une soixantaine de pays
on a l'impression que l'afghanistan
redevienne le lieu de confrontation au
milieu d'un certain nombre de jeux de
puissances la russie la chine et les six
pays du voisinage et non des moindres
l'iran à l'ouest et le pakistan à l'est
merci beaucoup emmanuel dupuis d'avoir
été notre invité
ce soir nous avoir donc apporter votre
analyse sur ces deux dossiers merci à
vous les états unis à nouveau pointée du
doigt pour l'embargo économique qu'ils
imposent depuis près de 60 ans à cuba
pour la 29e fois et à une écrasante
majorité l'assemblée générale de l'onu
l'a de nouveau condamné hier au centre
de la communauté internationale 187 pays
sur les 193 représenté aux nations unies
réclament la levée de ces restrictions
mais il a la boiserie dans ce centre de
vaccination de la havane des cubains
assiste tout en se faisant vacciner à la
présentation annuelle du projet de
résolution pour exiger la levée de
l'embargo américain
comme presque chaque année depuis 29 ans
la majorité des états membres de l'onu
ont voté en faveur d'une résolution en
ce sens mais sans grand succès elle
réclame pour la revendication de cuba
c'est qu'ils nous laissent en paix c'est
de pouvoir vivre sans blocus et que la
persécution contre nos liens financiers
avec le reste du monde c'est ce nous
exigeons qu'un terme soit mis à la
manipulation justifiant cette
discrimination ainsi qu aux obstacles
opposés aux relations entre des cubains
qui vivent aux etats-unis et leurs
proches vivant à cuba une intervention
du ministre cubain des affaires
étrangères applaudi par l'assistance
sous l'administration obama en 2015 les
deux pays avaient rétabli leurs
relations
mais l'avènement de donald trump a vu
les tentatives de rapprochement entre
les deux pays balayé d'un revers de la
main
le désormais ex locataire de la maison
blanche avait aussi ajouté près de 250
nouvelles sanctions contre l'île et sa
population entraînant une crise de
l'énergie et notamment du carburant
l'économie cubaine est aujourd'hui à
bout de souffle
en tant que pays rencontrant tant de
difficultés et soumis à un tel blocus et
à de la censure
nous avons réussi à obtenir un certain
prestige dans le domaine de la
biotechnologie et nous avons développé
un arsenal scientifique basée sur la
biomédecine au service du développement
de la population cubaine et nous allons
même internationalisé cela en exportant
vers d'autres parties du monde
je ne suis pas une politicienne
il me semble qu'il devrait lever ce
blocus et nous laisser vivre en paix
après près de 60 ans de blocus l'onu
peinent toujours à se faire respecter
par les états unis sur les 193 pays
membres de l'instance internationale
184 ont voté en faveur de cette
résolution
trois se sont abstenus et seul
washington et tel aviv ont voté contre
les sanctions sont un moyen légitime
d'attendre des objectifs de politique
étrangère de sécurité nationale et
d'autres objectifs nationaux et
internationaux les états unis ne sont
pas les seuls à avoir ce point de vue où
cette pratique
les sanctions sont des outils de notre
effort plus large envers cuba pour y
faire avancer la démocratie promouvoir
le respect des droits humains aider le
peuple cubain a exercé des libertés
fondamentales entériné par la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
nous nous opposons par conséquent à
cette résolution l'embargo américain n'a
jamais permis le renversement du pouvoir
socialiste à cuba la havane assure que
depuis que les sanctions existent les
répercussions sur l'économie cubaine se
chiffrent en dizaines de milliards de
dollars de revenus perdus mais toujours
aux états unis joe biden s'attaque aux
armes à feu qui ont provoqué une
épidémie de violence selon le locataire
de la maison blanche pour plus de
précisions retrouve tout de suite notre
reporter thomas bonnin en direct de
washington bonsoir thomas
les armes à feu un sujet toujours
évidemment explosif outre atlantique où
il est très délicat de s'attaquer au
deuxième amendement de la constitution
oui c'était une des camps des promesses
de campagne de john dryden s'attaquer au
crime par arme à feu dans le pays avec
ces chiffres alarmants ces derniers mois
une hausse des homicides de 30% en 2020
par rapport à l'année 2019 et sur le
premier trimestre 2001 21 une hausse des
homicides l'encore de 24% par rapport à
la même période l'an dernier le
président américain indique que le
phénomène s'est aggravé depuis le début
de la pandémie il a donc annoncé
plusieurs mesures écouter la prise de
parole de joe biden je suis dans ce
domaine depuis longtemps il ya des
choses que nous savons efficace pour
réduire la violence armée et les crimes
violents et d'autres que nous ne
connaissons pas mais ce que nous savons
c'est que les vérification des
antécédents pour l'achat d'une arme à
feu sont importantes
l'interdiction des armes d'assaut et
déchargeant à grande capacité
personne n'a besoin d'avoir une arme qui
peut tirer plus de 30 40 50 voire
jusqu'à 100 cartouches
à moins que vous ne pensiez que les
serres portent des gilets en kevlar ou
autres une police de proximité et des
programmes pour assurer la sécurité des
quartiers et éviter les problèmes
entendu le joe biden souhaitait limiter
la possibilité d'acquérir une arme
d'assaut mais il se heurte au blocage
des élus républicains qui invoque le
seconde amendement de la constitution
américaine seconde amendement qui
invoque le droit du peuple de détenir et
de porter des armes ne doit pas être
transgressée leur job hayden appelle à
dépasser les clivages sur cette question
mais les républicains n'ont pas
véritablement le même diagnostic que lui
sur la raison de cette hausse des
homicides il estime pour beaucoup que
cette hausse est liée aux manifestations
qui ont secoué le pays l'an dernier avec
notamment des appels à réformer et à
réduire les subventions allouées à la
police qui serait selon eux à l'origine
de cette hausse de la criminalité ils
prennent les exemples à des grandes
villes américaines qui sont dirigés par
des ailes
le démocrate et ils appellent de leur
côté renforcé les effectifs de police la
question et l'on est donc loin d'être
tranchée ici aux états unis on sait que
beaucoup d'anciens présidents se sont
cassé les dents sur ce dossier épineux
de la limitation des armes à feu alors
joe biden dit garder espoir mais face au
blocage parlementaire qui l'attend pas
sûr que le président américain puisse
aller aussi loin qu'ils le souhaitent et
aussi loin qu'il l'avait annoncé pendant
sa campagne
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington reste avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur les
divisions au sein du gouvernement
français avec des passes d'armes cette
semaine entre des ministres dans le
sillage de la déroute aux régionales
et puis nous parlerons du déplacement de
jean castex et d'olivier verrons dans
les landes sur le thème du variant
indien il représenterait 70 % des cas
positifs
[Musique]
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes 2 bouleverse
nous bouleverse toujours vous savez
parce qu'on les comprend pas il nous
touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez lancé c'est quoi c'est de
faire de la pédagogie c'est de faire
mieux que ça c'est de recréer des liens
que la politique n'arrive plus à renault
alors c'est à dire que la culture c'est
au dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit
des vérités que nous disent personne ni
les politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni
les journalistes et nous même si rennes
c'est la même culture c'est la même
façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons je suis optimiste
tout est pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
allemand
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qu'ils soient publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
un bon soir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 24 juin des
clash au sein du gouvernement les
retrouvailles hier en conseil des
ministres ont donné lieu à des passes
d'armes entre gérald darmanin eric
dupond-moretti mais aussi entre
elizabeth bourne et barbara pompili si
emmanuel macron a sifflé la fin de la
récré il n'en est pas moins attendu sur
sa stratégie après la déroute aux
régionales et à neuf mois de la
présidentielle
nous en parlerons dans quelques instants
avec notre éditorialiste alexis poulain
sept mille doses supplémentaires de
vaccins anti covini des quatorze mille
têtes vont être distribués dans les
landes le premier ministre annonce un
plan à d'actions de 7 jours pour contrer
la progression du variant delta dans ce
département du sud ouest confrontée à un
regain de l'épidémie
jean castex est rendu sur place aux
côtés de son ministre de la santé il
appelle à faire beaucoup mieux en
matière de vaccination et le variant
delta qui poursuit sa progression dans
le nombre pays et inquiète tous ont
secoué sa région enregistre des records
de contamination à sydney en australie
les habitants sont à nouveau interdites
quitté la ville après la détection d'un
cluster quant à l'afrique du sud elle
subit de plein fouet une troisième vague
virulente le pays et de plus loin de
loin le plus touché du continent
africain
en thaïlande et dans de contestation
malgré la flambée épidémique des
rassemblements ont eu lieu ce jeudi
alors que les autorités les avaient
interdites des défilés en opposition au
gouvernement pour demander la démission
du premier ministre pointé du doigt sur
sa stratégie vaccinale alors que
certaines régions du pays commencent à
accueillir des touristes étrangers
[Musique]
une semaine sous tension pour les
membres du gouvernement mais aussi pour
le parti de la majorité après son revers
cinglant au premier tour des régionales
dimanche dernier pour plus de précisions
nous retrouvons tout de suite mot namouh
dès lors en direct de l'elysée bonsoir
mona après le premier tour une passe
d'armes entre gérald darmanin eric
dupond moretti
une nouvelle si j'ose me racontez nous
mais on peut dire que les lendemains de
défaite ne sont jamais simples pour
certains à l'altercation se passe peu
avant le conseil des ministres entre le
premier flic de france et l'ancien ténor
du barreau sur un sujet très récent est
les régionales le garde des sceaux a
reproché à son collègue d'avoir
chaleureusement félicité xavier bertrand
qui est arrivé en tête dans la région
hôte france région dans laquelle dupond
moretti était également le candidat
écouter dharmanand vous connaissez mon
estime pour xavier bertrand il a été
récompensé pour son bilan
j'appelle sans difficulté à voter pour
lui c'est un ami vous le savez et je
suis un homme de droite j'ai toujours
été clair là dessus le président le sait
la majorité le sait je ne trahis
personnes défaite difficile à avaler a
selon dupont moretti c'est une trahison
de la part de dharmanand je cite
dupond-moretti félicité xavier bertrand
pour son bilan
c'est une trahison tu ne peux pas
marcher sur tes collègues c'est une
question de loyauté
et mona lagarde le garde des sceaux
aurait été particulièrement touché par
sa défaite aux élections régionales
oui ce n'est pas ni après l'annoncé des
résultats
eric dupond-moretti n'a pas fait de
déclarations il aura fallu attendre deux
jours pour qu'enfin ils tweetent je
voterai sans état d'âme pour xavier
bertrand mais souvenez vous est ce n'est
pas la première fois que les deux hommes
ne s'affrontent il ya quelques mois le
ministre de la justice indiqué qu'il
n'utiliserait jamais le terme ans
sauvagement les termes employés par
gérald darmanin et ce n'est pas la salle
altercation avant le conseil des
ministres von ah oui ça continue ce
n'est pas la seule avant le conseil des
ministres ce fut au tour de la ministre
du travail elisabeth bornes de s'en
prendre à barbara pompili la ministre de
la transition écologique
elisabeth bornes elle lui aurait
reproché d'avoir saluer la décision du
conseil d'état sur la suspension des
nouvelles règles de calcul de
l'assurance chômage en actes qui
auraient aidé plus fortement à la
ministre du travail
et c'est à ce moment que le chef de
l'état mona a sifflé la fin de la
récréation
vous y arrivez après cette énième
altercation emmanuel macron est arrivé
dans un climat quelque peu électrique
qu'il a remis les pendules à l'heure ont
notamment sur cette fameuse question de
l'assurance chômage en déclarant que
féliciter la décision du conseil d'état
s'est aussi inacceptable que déloyale en
tout cas ça a le mérite d'être clair
pour barbara pompili en tout cas
l'ambiance qui règne au sein de
l'exécutif relance une nouvelle loi une
nouvelle fois pardon là les rumeurs d'un
possible remaniement
cet été avec un emmanuel macron qui veut
avoir le meilleur casting pour aborder
la présidentielle d'ici quelques mois
car le chef de l'état le sait il doit
avoir une équipe solide et soudée pour
pouvoir espérer fédérer et rassembler
les français autour de lui merci monaco
dès lors en direct de la place beauvau
merci à vous et nous sommes maintenant
avec alexis poulain éditorialise bonsoir
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france la semaine d'entre
deux tours à on l'aura compris avec ce
reportage de monein monde et l'or n'a
pas été de tout repos sein de la
majorité gérald darmanin eric
dupond-moretti mais aussi les événements
des barbes à la pompe il y quelques que
cela traduit une certaine fatigue je
pense au sein de l'exécutif où chacun a
vécu cette campagne de manière difficile
dure des ministres qui n'était pas
habitué à faire campagne de cette façon
là on se rappelle à un eric dupond
moretti dans le nord collant des
affiches avec ses montres de luxe ses
boutons de manchette
ce faisant affective et par le candidat
du rassemblement national pour lui cette
campagne a sans doute été une certaine
violence personnelle
il n'est pas habitué à ce genre
d'affaires et perdre de cette façon là
on l'a vu quitter la salle le soir de
l'annoncé des résultats laissant son
collègue de la république en marche
annonçant la défaite lui préférant
éviter les caméras ce soir là je pense
que pour l'ego d'eric dupond-moretti ça
a été très dur
cette défaite et pour les autres
ministres également je pense que c'est
quelque chose peut-être qu'il s'y
attendait mais pas forcément à ce point
là
en l'occurrence pour eric dupond moretti
s'est même dans son village natal qui se
retrouvent à perdre donc c'est un
camouflet énorme pour ce ministre de la
république en marche et on se rend bien
compte que le en même temps ne
fonctionne pas lors des temps de tension
d'un côté gérald darmanin qui se dit
homme de droite qui félicite son ami
xavier bertrand lui aussi il ya et maire
de tourcoing donc il connaît la région
nord et il fait l' acte d'allégeance
d'une certaine façon à son parti
historique les républicains ou du moins
cette droite historique de laquelle il
vient et et du côté de eric dupond
moretti
ça ne passe pas évidemment puisque c'est
un coup de poignard de plus et on a vu
évidemment cette quasi altercation qui
va se finir à autour d'un bon plat comme
les affectionne le ministre de la
justice puisque les deux hommes ont
prévu de déjeuner la semaine prochaine
pour se rabibocher
donc c'est de la politique politicienne
mais ça en dit long sur la fin du en
même temps finalement je crois que là
emmanuel macron n'arrive plus à tenir
ses troupes par gros temps
alors le parti de la majorité se fissure
on l'aura compris à plusieurs endroits
d'ailleurs mais est ce qu'on peut parler
encore de partie quand l'ancrage
territorial fait cruellement défaut
alors c'est vrai que c'est une vraie
question
toutes les élections intermédiaires ont
été une catastrophe pour la république
en marche les municipales moins de 2% du
corbeau temps les listes de la
république en marche aux régionales qui
font autour de 10% et moi si on regarde
le corps des votants là on est au mois
-2 4% et on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas
d'élus finalement de 7 de ce nouveau
mouvement dans les régions dans les
villes dans les départements dans les la
décentralisation finalement c'est un
parti réellement hors sol qui ne vit que
par paris à la fois surtout à
l'assemblée nationale où il y à de
nombreux élus qui ont pu être
justement à accéder à la députation
suite à l'élection d' emmanuel macron
ses députés nombreux marcheurs souvent
appelée député playmobil
parce que vos temps d'un comme un seul
homme sur toutes les lois imposées par
l'exécutif
ce qui a d'ailleurs fait beaucoup de mal
à la démocratie représentative
ce qui explique aussi peut-être
l'abstention quand on voit la façon dont
les débats ont été très mal gérée par
cette majorité pendant ces quatre années
de mandat d' emmanuel macron donc il ya
vraiment un problème puisque au delà de
la sphère parisienne les ministères et
l'assemblée le parti la république en
marche le mouvement la république en
marche n'existe pas ne s'incarne pas
d'ailleurs il est question en ce moment
de s'autodissoudre pour les marcheurs
avec stanislas guérini qui à la tête du
mouvement et qui est remis en cause
et l'idée est bien sûr de noyer cette
marque que la république grand marche
qui est devenu une marque contre
productive qui ne vend plus du tout dans
une nouvelle majorité présidentielle
plus large une maison commune comme elle
est appelée ou au militerait pour de
nouvelles causes pour préparer une
nouvelle candidature d' emmanuel macron
donc on voit bien que c'est la fin d'un
marche même si aujourd'hui le parti l'a
très bien financièrement puisqu'il grâce
au système français tel qu'il est fait
il est assis sur une manne de plusieurs
millions d'euros il a pu acheter un
nouveau siège social en plein coeur de
paris et prépare bien sûr la campagne
présidentielle avec cet argent
même si il va se répandre et comme on le
fait en start up nation c'est-à-dire
changer de nom même si le contenu
restera le même en l'argent n'est pas
tout parce que à moins d'un an de la
présidentielle
il est peut-être urgent qu emmanuel
macron propose une ligne claire mais
quelle ligne c'est toute la question et
la difficulté pour lui puisqu'il a été
élu en 2010 est sur un projet un projet
évanescent un projet invisible un projet
qu'il a inventé finalement au fur et à
mesure puisque son programme était
extrêmement fluctuants il l'avait promis
de ne pas allonger
de décaler l'âge du départ à la retraite
eh bien il le fait avec les réformes des
retraites il est revenu à peu près sûr
tous ses engagements de campagne
il a sans arrêt dit tout et son
contraire et même la croix une façon
d'être et de ne pas être qui lui permet
d'être tout à la fois aérien en même
temps c'est ça la le en même temps c'est
ça en marche et aujourd'hui ça ne marche
plus et on voit bien d'ailleurs avec le
gouvernement qui était est en train de
se déliter sous nos yeux et pour être
manuel macron depuis quatre ans on voit
que systématiquement il a pris le choix
de devenir un président de droite alors
droite républicaine
il essaye maintenant de casser les
républicains s'étaient sont paris pour
les régionales il n'y est pas arrivé
donc que va-t-il faire face à ça et puis
la course contre marine le pen qui est
pour lui une opposante rêver puisqu'il
pourrait faire un match retour en 2022
comme il l'a fait en 2017 en étant à peu
près sûr d'être élu se disant qu' il y
aura un front républicain contre marine
le pen
rien n'est moins sûr comme on le voit
d'ailleurs en paca avec thierry mariani
candidat et rennes qui est au coude à
coude avec renaud muselier qui a
pourtant reçu le soutien de la
république en marche donc pourrait mener
le maquereau et l'heure est à
l'éclaircissement à savoir quelle va
être sa fin de mandat et surtout quel va
être son programme pour la suite va-t-il
s'assumer comme un président de droite
et essayer de récupérer davantage de l
air ou va-t-il essayer à nouveau en même
temps nouvelle ré invention qui risque
de ne pas fonctionner parce que
maintenant les français le connaissent
est ce qu'un remaniement ministériel
serait une solution c'est que les
présidents affectionne cet exercice en
france alors un remaniement ministériel
peut-être quand on sait que cinq
ministres ont perdu au premier tour ça
va être difficile pour eux d'assurer le
service après vente avec le peu de
légitimité qu'ils ont mais la difficulté
c'est de trouver les candidats pour les
quelques mois qui restent sachant que
laxiste et riels va s'arrêter très tôt
la campagne va commencer à partir de
mars à être dans le dur puisque
l'élection est maintenant en avril nous
avons les dates
donc c'est quelque chose de compliqué à
la fois de trouver des candidats et puis
de renouveler cette équipe pour le
quelques temps qui reste donc ce serait
une équipe uniquement communicationnel
qu'ils seraient là pour être tous porte
parole en quelque sorte
hélas
macron a besoin de personne en qui il
peut totalement compter et je ne vois
pas qui aujourd'hui il pourrait recruter
de cette façon là en étant sûr à 100%
que cela feront sa campagne jusqu'au
bout en étant sûr de défendre un bilan
qui aujourd'hui est difficile à défendre
et puis il ya autre chose s'il
souhaitait remercier jean castex c'est
aussi difficile parce que la crise
sanitaire n'est pas terminé on parle du
variant delta dans les landes alors on
se réjouit parce que la vaccination
continue elle semblerait marché mais
devant ces variants rien n'est moins sûr
et peut-être que en septembre octobre la
crise sanitaire sera toujours là et dans
ce cas là s'il change d'équipé alors que
le coe vie de revient c'est une
catastrophe
et même des personnes comme olivier rang
devrait aller jusqu'au bout et d'être le
ministre du koweit en quelque sorte
jusqu'à ce que l'épisode soit clos si un
jour il se ferme
mais en l'occurrence aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement critique de changer les
ministres un gouvernement alors
peut-être un remaniement à la marge
comme on l'a déjà vu par le passé mais
je ne pense pas que jean castex puisse
être remercié aussi facilement cet été
merci alexis poulain d'avoir été avec
nous et à parier aujourd'hui ce
rassemblement devant le ministère de la
santé pour le maintien des hôpitaux
bichat et beaujon notre reporter qu'elle
sape ethniques étaient sur place
un rassemblement était organisé à
l'appel des syndicats fo et cgt de
l'assistance publique et le collectif
inter urgence il a regroupé des
personnels hospitaliers médicaux et non
médicaux
un cortège à ces déplacés depuis
l'hôpital beaujon l'objectif est de dire
non au projet de fermeture des hôpitaux
bichat et beaujon il est prévu qu'ils
soient fusionnés en un seul hôpital dans
le 93 pour remplacer donc anne hôpital
parisien et l'hôpital aux portes de
paris
dans la manoeuvre les syndicats parlent
de 1000 postes supprimés 400 lits en
moins alors les manifestants ont demandé
au ministre de la santé olive et veyran
de maintenir et poursuivre la rénovation
de ces hôpitaux de maintenir leurs
services de proximité d'excellence et de
maintenir évidemment tous les postes de
travail il dit
en outre 100 lits supplémentaires à
l'hôpital hôtel dieu à paris je vous
propose d'écouter trois syndicalistes
nous avons fermé cent mille lits en 25
ans en france c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle l'hôpital public a été en
grande difficulté pour prendre en charge
les malades atteints de l'aco vide donc
il faut arrêter ces fermetures de lits
il faut même en rouvrir dans un certain
nombre d'endroits soif que aujourd'hui
et bien les programmes de
restructuration de fermetures de lits
sont toujours à l'ordre du jour ce
moment des opérations financières vous
savez c'est toujours le même thème
il faut faire des économies sur le
budget de la sécurité sociale
sauf que si nous avions eu plus de lits
plus de livres pour gérer ses
différentes vagues de l'aco vide qui
aurait peut-être eu moins de morts
je pense que c'est une situation qui est
très très compliqué comme tous les
hospitaliers en france
c'est une situation il manque des lits
où il manque des postes où il n'y a pas
forcément de volonté de grosse volonté
de recrutement de ou de hospitalier à
l'hôpital
c'est une situation où on manque de tout
la crise ducobu da montrer qu'on
manquait énormément de moyens
et là on s'aperçoit qu'après donc la
troisième vague ben on manque encore
plus de moyens que au début de la
première vague très en réanimation n'a
manqué on a manqué dix pendant la crise
du coc vide il ya des passants quand on
n'a pas pu soigner qu'on a qui ont été
déclarés à nos réanimatoires faute de
place dans les lits il faut le dire
et donc voilà d'avoir vécu tout ça c'est
difficile
alors cette manifestation est plus large
que la l'opposition à cette fusion elle
vient dénoncer la volonté de fermeture
de lits du gouvernement qui menacent
d'autres hôpitaux comme à garches et à
beaumont sur oise il souhaite un
moratoire pour un arrêt des fermetures
de lits en france alors que l'hôpital
est bien sûr en grande tension une
délégation a été reçue par un conseiller
à l'offre de soins du ministre olive et
veyran qui lui était en déplacement dans
les landes il a dit relayer l'info au
ministre pour lui demander de venir à
l'hôpital beaujon car le critère de
fermeture et qu'il serait vétuste les
syndicalistes se sont dits déçus par
cette entrevue
ils vont prévoir d'autres rassemblements
pour amplifier la mobilisation
lisa sion ici devant le ministère de la
santé et sur le front du coc bid le
variant delta qui inquiète de plus en
plus les autorités françaises
jean castex et le mini de la santé se
sont rendus ce matin dans les landes où
le taux d'incidence est repassé au
dessus des 54 pour cent mille habitants
et j'entends l'ensemble des français à
se faire vacciner le premier ministre a
annoncé une série de mesures pour
juguler l'épidémie dans ce département
du sud ouest
sept mille doses supplémentaires de
vaccins anti copie des quatorze mille
tests vont être distribuées
prochainement un nouveau cluster
également dans le bas rhin et pour en
parler nous sommes avec thierry amouroux
porte-parole syndicats infirmiers
syndicat national des personnels
infirmiers bonsoir thierry moreau merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france jean castex qui a aussi lancé à
nouveau un appel aux soignants dernier
rappel avant que la vaccination devienne
obligatoire pour les soignants il est
indispensable que les soignants soient
vaccinés pour protéger leurs patients
qui sont qui sont fragiles
alors il faut savoir que c'est déjà le
cas dans de nombreux endroits selon les
chiffres du bulletin de santé publique
france qui a été publiée au mois de mai
à 91% des soignants sont vaccinés dans
les hôpitaux
ça tombe à 63% dans les ehpad
mais il faut savoir qu'il y a quand même
petit souci de décalage technique dans
le temps à savoir que vous avez 125 dit
le soignant qui ont été contaminés par
par le cos vide 70 à l'hôpital 55000
dans les ehpad et qu' il ya un délai de
plusieurs mois entre le moment où on est
infecté par un kobe et le moment on a
une injection du vaccin ce qui explique
un peu ce décalage 63% ça n'explique
peut-être pas voilà se rendre guillemets
mauvais chiffre clairement thierry
amouroux pour vous rendre obligatoire
cette vaccination tout du moins pour les
soignants est ce que ce serait voilà la
solution indispensable même si elle peut
être décriée dans notre pays
le fils se vacciner c'est une obligation
morale déontologique pour pour les
soignants après le fait de laurent
obligatoire par la loi
ça peut avoir des effets
contre-productifs
d'abord on voyait un message à
l'ensemble de la population que les
soignants serait réticent la vaccination
encore une fois 91% des soignants à
l'hôpital sont vaccinés et c'est là où
il ya la majorité des soignants sont pas
dans les étals sont dans les hôpitaux
les chu c'était quand même dans les
ehpad
oui bien entendu c'est pour ça que je
vous dis qu'ils aient l'obligation
morale et déontologie après sur le
jusqu'à présent pour convaincre nos
patients de se vacciner on s'appuie
justement sur le fait que nous soignants
nous sommes vaccinés et on met en avant
cette exemplarité
et les français majoritairement elles
étaient sceptiques en décembre dernier
et puis aujourd'hui est bien la grande
majorité de la population souhaitent se
faire vacciner
et ça ça a été un travail de réaliser
sur le terrain en s'appuyant sur le
médecin de famille sur sur l'infirmière
habituel et donc c'est nous par le fait
que l'on soit vacciné on s'appuie
là-dessus on leur dit pour regarder moi
je me suis vacciné s
allez-y il faut le faire c'est important
voilà et si demain il ya cette
vaccination obligatoire on ne pourra
plus utiliser aussi facilement cet
argument parce que des légions pour être
heureux nous dire bah oui mais vous êtes
à signer mais c'est parce que c'est
obligatoire c'est pas de votre plein gré
donc ça envoie un message un peu bizarre
parce que encore une fois 91% d'aidé
soignant à l'hôpital sont vaccinés
aujourd'hui comme auront quatre sont les
arguments qu'ils avancent ces soignants
quand ils ne sont pas pardon à vacciner
il ne le souhaite pas il se méfier quel
armement
il faut bien comprendre que c'est une
minorité lorsqu'on regarde par exemple
en israël dans le plus grand hôpital de
jérusalem
vous aviez 80 agents réfractaires sur
sur 3000 vous avez la même situation en
italie ou en angleterre pour que c'est
ultra minoritaire
comprenez bien que l'hélice réunion ont
l'habitude de se vacciner parce qu'ils y
croient
et il ya déjà un certain nombre de
vaccins obligatoires donc c'est dans
notre adn
merci en tout cas thierry morin d'avoir
été notre invité ce soir en direct sur
rt france et au brésil à présent le pays
est touché par une troisième vague de
kobe le triste cap des 500 milles morts
a été franchi la population s'inquiète
face à une recrudescence des cas les
détails depuis sao paulo avec agosta de
nardi après avoir franchi samedi dernier
le seuil des 500 milles morts le brésil
a battu hier un nouveau et triste record
plus de 5 15 mille nouveaux cas
d'infection aux convives 19 ont été
recensés en 24 heures confirmant
l'arrivée d'une troisième vague alors
que la deuxième n'était pas vraiment
fini le nombre d'infections quotidienne
est en hausse constante depuis plus d'un
mois et de la moyenne de décès tourne
autour de 2000 par jour depuis la
semaine dernière mais ce qui inquiète
les médecins et les chercheurs
spécialistes c'est surtout un nouvel
effondrement du système de santé la
situation est déjà critique dans 19 des
27 états brésiliens avec plus de 80 %
d'occupation des lits en réanimation le
même 90% dans huit d'entre eux et quand
on la vaccination les chiffres avance
encore trop lentement seuls 30 % de la
population a reçu au moins une dose et
11% et complètement vaccinés à 100 voire
l'eau par exemple la plus grande ville
du pays où je me trouve actuellement la
vaccination a dû être interrompu mardi
faute de deux disponibles et malgré la
situation sanitaire préoccupante la vie
semble être pratiquement revenue à la
normale dans la plupart des villes du
pays avec des restaurants des bars et
des commerces au vert et un grand nombre
de personnes sans masque dans les rues
en comportement encouragé par les
déclarations du président jaillir wolson
arrow qui n'a cessé de minimiser la
dangerosité du virus et de remettre en
cause les mesures de restriction prises
par les maires et les gouverneurs
brésilien restait vêtements dans
quelques instants
nous continuerons de parler de la
pandémie et cette fois en afrique du sud
pays qui a enregistré un tiers des
contaminations en cours en amérique du
continent africain et puis nous
parlerons des manifestations
pro-démocratiques à bangkok en thaïlande
malgré la vague de covile 19
[Musique]
l'arctique cet endroit où l'eurasie
l'amérique du nord et l'asie pacifique
se rend compte est en train de devenir
un lieu de tension majeure dans
l'équilibré géopolitique mondiale
l'évolution climatique laisse prévoir
que le sait en arctique sera totalement
libre de glace est ouvert la navigation
vers 2040 2050
il est clair qu'au delà de la route
maritime la fonte des glaces ouvre
l'accès à d'énormes possibilités
les européens comme les américains ont
tardé à prendre conscience des défis
économiques et militaires qui pointe
derrière l'enjeu environnemental plus la
glace fond et plus les appétits
grossistes mme
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk heures nous
sommes au bord de la volga le plus long
fleuve d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière poche la france était
en 2011 monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui c'est tous les fromages tous
les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne le savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues kb
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
feront normalement les cellules
sensibles à la lumière dans la rétine
parce qu'il va dire qu'il voit un peu
c'est il distingue la lumière il
distingue quoi exactement par le patient
et le pain par exemple de reconnaître
les passages protégés dans la rue le
détecter des objets différents objets de
petite taille de grande taille à
plusieurs niveaux en passe de les
compter de les attraper et comme c'est
un patient qui ne voyait plus rien
depuis une quinzaine d'années c'est déjà
une source d'espoir c'est évidemment pas
un point définitif du parcours c'est une
étape franchie
[Musique]
il ne cesse d'augmenter et devrait
atteindre cette année 9 4% du pib
français
un record on parle bien sûr du déficit
public quand vous avez un déficit de
près de 10% et que vous allez faire
peut-être quatre peut-être 5% de
croissance
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant eh bien
vous êtes en récession de 6 quoi en gros
c'est ça que ça veut dire mais plutôt
dans une stratégie de dirigeants lahlou
15 après moi le déluge
mais le déluge s'il va finir par arriver
si l'on continue à avoir ce type de
désinvolture et d'insouciance vis-à-vis
de la situation de nos finances
publiques qui a beaucoup d'activités qui
sont plus habiles bras et qui le jour où
il n'y a plus de n'y a plus d' aides
vont s'effondrer
on continue à espérer et dans
l'efficacité d'un plan de relance qui
est totalement inappropriée et
totalement perpendiculaires aux besoins
de l'économie française
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtel c'est par un
théâtre comme les autres c'est un
théâtre qui est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein au film ans on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez la russie
préoccupe elle aussi par la situation
sanitaire dans la capitale moscou et sa
région enregistre des records de
contamination liée aux variants delta
afin d'endiguer cette flambée épidémique
impasse sanitaire va être mis en place
pour accéder aux un restaurant la
correspondance d'antoine claireaux à
partir de lundi il faudra montrer patte
blanche pour pouvoir entrer dans les
restaurants de la capitale
en effet au vu de la dégradation de la
situation sanitaire les autorités
municipales ont décidé de frapper fort à
partir du 28 juin 2021
seuls ceux qui sont protégés contre le
coc vide 19 pourront fréquenter les
restaurants ceux qui se sont fait
vacciner ceux qui ont été infectés par
le comique 19 au cours des six derniers
mois
ceux qui ont un test pc un négatif de -2
3 jours concrètement il faudra à l'aide
de son téléphone montré un qr code comme
celui ci comme quoi on est bien
immunisés cette mesure inspirée de ce
qui a déjà été fait en israël lors de
son déconfinement a été adopté en
conséquence de la flambée de kobe de
constater ces dernières semaines en
grande partie à cause du variant delta
les restaurateurs pour leur part cherche
avant tout à éviter le scénario de
l'année dernière lorsqu'il avait dû
fermer leur établissement pendant de
longs mois
donc il s'adapte en général nous faisons
attention à la santé des gens ici pour
le moment toutes les mesures prises ne
suffisent pas alors d'autres mesures
sont nécessaires à la vaccination est
l'une de ces mesures c'est tout c'est
très simple nous nous plaidons pour la
santé de la nation la clientèle elle est
plus partagé vous savez nos invités
réagissent différemment tout comme elles
réagissent différemment aux vaccins ils
réagissent à doter les expériences tout
comme ils réagissent aux vaccins les
gens sont différents
je sais que c'est pas bien premièrement
des personnes vaccinées non vaccinés
sont séparées les unes des autres ce qui
me semble t'il entraînera des
protestations à l'avenir je n'aime pas
ça moi personnellement je suis contre la
vaccination
je ne prévois pas de me faire vacciner
je n'ai pas l'intention de le faire bien
que je sois propriétaire d'une
entreprise
quant à mes employés je ne vais pas les
appeler à le faire non plus je le répète
encore une fois j'ai eu une approche
prudente envers cette question
j'aimerais avoir plus d'information à
propos de cela avant de prendre cette
décision de me faire vacciner
il faut dire que la situation de ces
derniers jours de ces dernières semaines
est très préoccupante
malheureusement la situation est
complexe
aujourd'hui nous sommes presque au pic
de l'incidence si on compare avec les
périodes précédentes
mais ce qui est encourageant c'est que
les gens ont tout de même commencé à se
faire vacciner plus activement je ne
sais pas si vous le constatez selon
l'affluence à vos points de vaccination
hier un nombre record de vaccination a
été enregistré environ 60 milles
récemment on était tombé jusqu'à environ
6000 par jour le nombre d'inscriptions à
la vaccination est presque multiplié par
dix c'est encourageant
cela signifie que dans les mois à venir
les moscovites peuvent obtenir une
protection fiable contre la pandémie et
stabiliser la situation revenir à une
vie normale
résultat les autorités décident
d'adopter des mesures contraignantes en
espérant que celles-ci portent leurs
fruits
ce variant delta qui s'est vite
également en australie notamment à
signer ou 1 kloster a été détectée les
amis tentent à nouveau interdiction de
quitter la ville et le port du masque
devient obligatoire dans les transports
et les commerces
florian lambert signer et l'australie
une nouvelle fois confronté au risque
d'un regain épidémique
après l'apparition des premiers cas du
variant delta la semaine dernière dans
le quartier de bondi beach à sydney
c'est plus de 30 personnes qui ont été
déclarées positives au co vite 19 ces
derniers jours l'espoir d'une sortie de
crise sanitaire s'amenuisent alors que
melbourne la deuxième plus grande ville
du pays avait levé les restrictions
après deux semaines de confinement et
une baisse significative du nombre de
cas une situation prise immédiatement au
sérieux par les autorités australiennes
la première ministre de la nouvelle
galles du sud a annoncé l'entrée en
vigueur de l'interdiction de quitter
sydney à compter de ce mercredi sauf
pour quelques motifs impérieux les
restrictions que nous annonçons seront
en vigueur à partir de 16h aujourd'hui
pour une semaine supplémentaire jusqu'à
mercredi minuit cela s'appliquera
désormais aux restrictions que j'annonce
donc pas plus de cinq visiteurs par
foyer dans les lieux d'accueil pas de
consommation debout toutes les personnes
doit être assise où que vous soyez dans
tous les cas nous ne voulons pas que les
gens se mélangent et gars ça signifiera
le transfert du virus une interdiction
de déplacement hors de la ville qui
s'ajoute au retour du port du masque
obligatoire dans les transports et
commerces à sydney le nombre de
personnes autorisées à se rassembler de
nouveau limité et si les bars et
restaurants resteront ouverts il sera
désormais interdit de chanter de danser
lancé d'établissement les autorités néo
zélandaises ont également renforcé les
restrictions à wellington après qu'un
habitant de sydney ayant passé son
week-end dans la capitale de l'archipel
a été testé positif à son retour
l'australie comptabilise aujourd'hui
près de 30000 4 de kobe 19 cependant 6,7
des 25 millions d'habitants du pays ont
reçu une première dose de vaccination
l'afrique du sud à présent de loin le
pays le plus touché du continent
africain avec 1,8 million de cas et près
de soixante mille décès le pays fait
face à une troisième vague dont la
gestion par les autorités est largement
critiqué le président ramaphosa appelle
à respecter les mesures de distanciation
social le gouverneur de la province de
gauteng qui regroupe johannesburg et
pretoria reconnaît lui que la pandémie
est hors de contrôle avec des hôpitaux
saturés et à peine de 3 25% de la
population vaccinée pour l'instant et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis johannesburg avec alan critères
médecins généralistes et notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir à la
napster merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france invoque est à
johannesbourg expliquez-nous
concrètement qu elle est là la situation
sur place
la situation ici est grave
les hôpitaux sont pleins même les
hôpitaux privés au privé les hôpitaux de
l'état
nous n'avons que vacciner qu'un port
sont de la partie de la population est
maintenant c'est très difficile de
trouver un livre franchement de trouver
liés il faut attendre que quelqu'un est
décédé pour rentrer dans les hôpitaux
et il ya plusieurs raisons pourquoi de
la faction le déroulement des vaccins de
vaccination était si on en attend c'est
à cause d'eux il ya beaucoup de pays
riches qui ont acheté des des massifs
stocks de vaccins et puis le astrazeneca
il y avait un recherche locale qui
donnait le résultat que les vaccins et
n'était pas si efficaces contre le coc
vie donc légères et modérées
donc on arrêtait le déroulement la vente
de l'évêque saint d'astrazeneca
puis on a commencé avec les johnson &
johnson et après à moi de rues de
le déroulement de jocelyn jack johnson
on a trouvé des quelques thrombose dont
les états unis donc on a arrêté encore
le déroulement de vaccination ici en
afrique du sud
et puis maintenant quand on en a besoin
d'acheter sur les forums d india on a
trouvé les crises on line en ans l'inde
était si grave qu'elle ne peut pas
donner les doses dans les pays en
afrique
donc voilà où nous sommes nous sommes
maintenant le chief oui pardonnez moi on
sent vraiment peut-être un manque de
chance dans la stratégie parce que c'est
vrai que le gouvernement on imagine ne
pouvait peut-être pas anticiper tous les
problèmes dont vous nous parler ça veut
dire que voilà ils ont misé sur des
vaccins malheureusement qui se sont
avérés ne pas être forcément les les
bons en tout cas avec une défiance pour
ce qui est de d'astrazeneca rolls et en
europe aussi
oui non c'est vrai parce que c'est pas
tout à fait leur faute mais aussi on n'a
pas préparé dès le début de cette
pandémie d'acheter les vaccins à l'heure
et maintenant les chiffres augmentent
chaque jour 2 en janvier février il y
avait presque un mille nouveaux cas
maintenant ce salaire à 13000 est
aujourd'hui lé hier c'était 17000 et
16000 avec 166 morts
aujourd'hui donc la pique va arriver
dans deux semaines donc c'est même si la
situation maintenant est grave mais ça
va aggraver davantage dans les
prochaines semaines aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on est en décalage
avec l'afrique du sud qui semblait quand
même mieux se porter d'ailleurs le
continent africain de manière globale se
portait mieux que l'europe l'europe va
mieux
quel est le regard de médecins que vous
portez sur voilà ces décalages en
fonction des continents des pays mêmes
on a pris deux buts à 2 du retard contre
les autres pays en afrique australiens
ont même on est dernier à bangui pour
soi le nigeria sénégal avec le
déroulement de vaccination de tous moi
c'est une c'est très grave que ce soit
le cas mais il faut faire le mieux ce
qu'on peut faire avec le vaccin ona on a
déjà des gens à acheter
jeudi environ 50 millions de doses de
johnson & johnson
mais pour le moment c'est trop tard et
ce qui m'inquiète ce troisième vague va
encore inquiétant va être très sympa la
troisième vague eux ils ne sont pas dans
le troisième mais actuellement c'est
seulement quand elle autorise à
johannesburg et les médecins se sont
épuisés nous sommes presque au bout des
lèvres de nos forces et il faut
s'occuper plusieurs gens chaque jour et
c'est presque impossible de soigner un
tel nombre de médecins malades avec le
co vie c'est vraiment c'est clairement
vous en tant que médecin malgré les
problèmes dont vous nous avez parlé en
sueur c'est un vaccin dénommé russe
astrazeneca johnson johnson est ce que
vous encourager vraiment la population à
se faire vacciner est ce que là le
gouvernement les autorités en font assez
en matière de communication on croit
savoir que le ministre de la santé
d'ailleurs a été suspendue est ce qu'ils
en font assez dans cette pédagogie
bénéfice risque
ça c'est très important c'est vraiment
c'est bête de ne pas prendre le vaccin
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est parce que
le il y avait six cas de thrombose
vasculaire aux états unis et puis qu'on
a trouvé que la vaccin tréséné coeur
n'était pas
efficace contre le coc vide légèrement
atteints modéré atteint sa seule et les
doutes dont les gens en disant voilà le
vaccin n'est pas 100%
il n'y a pas cent soixante sécurité
contre le coc vie mais si on est
vaccinés ça va vous protéger contre les
locaux vides grave et dès qu'on est
gravement malade avec le co vit vraiment
c'est la chance qu'on peut survivre dans
ce cas c'est vraiment on ne sait pas à
ce qu'un pourcent sécurité de renvoi
sortie de l'hôpital le variant delta de
variants indien cause est la cause de
tous les maux en afrique du sud et le
saura aussi pour l'afrique un lot msa eu
des propos très alarmiste aujourd'hui
sur sur l'afrique qui pourrait beaucoup
souffrir de de ce variant oui il ya
encore maintenant le vin rayon delta
plus ici en afrique du sud
mais heureusement il n'y a pas des
recherches qui montrent que ces variants
sont plus meurtriers je dirais mais
c'est plus avec eux etc
c'est difficile avec de vivre avec le co
vide presque une en un an et demi parce
que les gens sont fatigués ils
commencent à se mélanger ensemble ils
commencent à fait baisser les masques
d'aller au restaurant ça on a besoin
dans la restauration sociale
à mon avis en ce moment on est sûr
nouveau 3 même je crois on va atteindre
près ce nouveau 4 dans les prochains
jours merci beaucoup en tout cas la
nappe 8h médecins généralistes merci en
tout cas nous avoir apporté votre
témoignage et bon courage en tout cas à
vous
en thaïlande élan de contestation malgré
la flambée des cas de kobe 19 des
rassemblements ont eu lieu ce jeudi
alors que les autorités les avaient
interdites des défilés en opposition au
gouvernement pour demander la démission
du premier ministre pointé du doigt sur
sa stratégie vaccinale
alors que certaines régions du pays
recommence à accueillir des touristes
étrangers les détails avec mehdi
escaffit
[Musique]
un contexte sanitaire inquiétant mais
des manifestations qui reprennent à
bangkok des centaines de protestataires
se sont rassemblés ce jeudi à l'occasion
de l'anniversaire de la révolution de
1932 un jour symbolique au cours duquel
de nombreux défilés ont lieu chaque
année les contestataires dénoncent les
emprisonnements de manifestants ou
encore la gestion de la pandémie par
l'exécutif il réclame toujours la
démission du premier ministre
aujourd'hui je veux venir ici pour
confirmer que ceux qui sont sortis des
prisons et ceux qui sont restés à
l'extérieur nous allons tous continuer
notre combat et continuer à réclamer nos
trois demandes nous continuerons à
parcourir ce chemin ensemble
peu importe ce qui nous attend ce qui a
eu lieu dans le passé nous le prendrons
comme une leçon nous nous améliorons
pour être prêt pour la suite
[Musique]
nous avons repoussé la barrière dans nos
revendications nous allons aller de
l'avant on nous débarrassons de la
dictature de prêt ou de chien le chat
pour tenter de se faire entendre
les manifestants ont défilé en direction
du parlement et ce malgré l'interdiction
de rassemblements instauré par les
autorités en raison de la crise
sanitaire
la thaïlande est toujours en pleine
vague épidémique avec plus de 3000
contamination quotidienne recensés
depuis plusieurs jours un bilan qui n'a
pas empêché l'office du tourisme du pays
de rouvrir sans quarantaine la province
de phuket une région située dans le sud
du royaume les visiteurs vacciner
pourront s'y rendre à partir du 1er
juillet le premier ministre se donne un
délai de trois mois pour la réouverture
totale du pays
le temps est maintenant venu pour nous
de regarder vers l'avenir et de fixer
une date à laquelle nous pourrons ouvrir
complètement notre pays ait commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs car la
réouverture du pays est l'un des moyens
importants pour commencer à réduire
l'énorme souffrance des personnes qui
ont perdu leur capacité à gagner un
revenu
je me fixe donc pour objectif de pouvoir
déclarer la thaïlande totalement
ouvertes dans les 120 jours à compter
d'aujourd'hui et pour les centres
touristiques qui sont près de le faire
encore plus rapidement
le tourisme un domaine clé pour
l'économie thaïlandaise en 2019 le pays
a reçu 40 millions de visiteurs avec des
recettes estimées à près de 53 milliards
d'euros un chiffre qui représente plus
de 12% du pib du pays
la crise sanitaire a depuis largement
ralenti l'afflux touristique avec
seulement 6,7 millions de touristes
accueillis en 2020 pour en parler nous
sommes avec david camroux professeur à
sciences po paris spécialiste de l'asie
du sud est
foire david camroux merci d'être avec
nous c'est quoi c'est la pandémie sa
gestion qui a mis le feu aux poudres en
thaïlande
le temps a toujours connu une vie agitée
et politique agitée depuis nous sont
rondeurs on est quoi d'où ce coup d'état
20 constitution est extraordinaire c'est
que malgré sa grâce à une fonction
publique un solide
la paix ne connais pas tellement de deux
ans fait de bouleversements mais ce qui
différencie cette fois c'est trois
choses premièrement c'est c'est une
révolte générale des innovations c'est
les jeunes qui ont dit ras-le-bol à ces
vieux qui nous dirigent vous avez vous
savez que le terrain sur le pays ou pour
les lycées on aime on impose la culture
des délits siens d'un ras-le-bol de ça
et deuxièmement deuxième aspect qui est
changé c'est que le rôle du roi avec le
roi rama 10
le roi va gerland cameron et est mis en
question parce que il est un acte
politique et il a fait en sorte que il a
de plus en plus au pouvoir et ils
troisième chose qui ait changé c'est
qu'à côté de la thaïlande en birmanie où
nous assistons à une rivale guerre
civile parce que on a eu un but purement
civil comme on fait souvent calandre
d'ailleurs où on vend ses parts en
cumulé militaire
donc nous sommes dans une est dans une
situation où ces trois éléments le vent
des innovations l'asb est international
et il aspire le col remise en cause du
rôle du roi se trouvent ensemble donc
pour le premier ministre thaïlandais
c'est une situation compliquée
ce mouvement de contestation qu'elle en
est précisément son ampleur est ce qu'on
doit craindre des violences a justement
l'instar de ce qui se passe en birmanie
pas ce point parce que les terrains de
les militaires thaïlandais contrairement
aux militaires birmans sont allés doute
il celle très bien joué et sûr en fait
la conciliation
nous non ce qu'on va assister c'est
simplement que c'est ce musulman qui
était très fort l'année dernière revient
en force après le coup vide ça s'est un
peu à cramer cosco vide à cause des mais
c'est quelque chose de très profondes en
fait c'est une vraie révolution comme en
trouve en birmanie c'est une révolution
des jeunes contre les les justement les
délais les vieux qui les plus petits les
deux gouverne et donc ce n'est pas
acceptable c'est une révolution disons
deux côtés du genre dans ces
manifestations beaucoup de femmes
beaucoup de lgbt est aussi celle rejet
commande émane et comment aussi en
allant d'une société très rachiq donc ça
s'appelle une révolution s'est dit que
c'est plus profond que nos politiques
paris lui demande politique très précis
que prévu comme prévu démissionne
conscience de constitution parce que
c'est quand même con succion
antidémocratique le sénat et les nommer
et n'est pas élu donc csp tout à fait
raisonnable malgré sorte de meurtre at
d'un changement politique mais aussi
profondément le rejet d'un suscité par
ea chic et
les jeunes contre les vieux clairement
comment les autorités répondent à cette
colère est ce que l était la hauteur
justement de ce mécontentement de la
population
mais le monde justement met en prison
les manifestants c'est très classique en
lui ce système judiciaire pour fêter la
l'opposition l'église les droits de
lèse-majesté
c'est sûr pays du nord de l existe des
doigts de l'essai dans les utilisent
pour fêter de l'opposition mais le
problème c'est que les militaires cas et
malgré tous les défauts étaient plutôt
efficace dans la gestion de l'économie
et c'est facile et ses soeurs ou
compétents avec aux technocrates syrie
mais là la réponse du géant prayuth de
premier ministre lui manque allant des
eaux convient d' un code en boucle ou
des pays de l'asie du sud-est a aussi
ailleurs et bien ce pasteur on a bien
géré la première vague mais on n'a pas
fait les faucons a fait en europe pour
la vaccination est donc là ils sont en
train de rattraper mais la gestion a
fait leur réputation des minis tère
d'être les gestionnaires efficaces et
comme mise en cause c'est à dire que tu
l'as fait légitime
on fait légitime de régime est mise en
cause par ces manifestants merci david
camroux d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france pour nous exposer la
situation thaïlande merci à vous
et dans le reste de l'actualité le
pionnier de l'anti virus informatique
john
mcafee s'est suicidé dans une prison de
barcelone l'homme d'affaires a été
retrouvé mort dans sa cellule quelques
heures plus tôt la justice espagnole
avait autorisé son extradition vers les
etats-unis où il était recherché pour
évasion fiscale
retour sur les faits avec yamina abed à
john mack et fille est retrouvé mort
dans sa cellule près de barcelone où il
était détenu depuis octobre 2020 son
décès a été constaté alors que quelques
heures plus tôt la haute cour espagnole
a autorisé son extradition vers les
etats-unis le créateur de l'antivirus
éponyme il était accusé de fraude
fiscale le 5 octobre 2020 un procureur
américain met en cause john mack et
fille pour avoir omis de déclarer des
millions de dollars de revenus issus de
la promotion de crypto monnaie il est
arrêté le lendemain par la police
espagnole à l'aéroport de barcelone
après qu'un mandat d'arrêt avait été
émis par interpol et que son extradition
avait été demandée il a gagné des
millions de dollars en faisant la
promotion de crypto monnaie mais aussi
en tant que consultant donnant des
conférences rémunérés et en vendant les
droits de sa biographie pour un
documentaire
le 16 juin dernier john mack et fille
s'était exprimé sur twitter pour
dénoncer ce qui selon lui constituer des
accusations infondées des états unis à
son encontre
les etats unis croient que j'ai de la
crypte monnaie dissimulé j'aimerais que
cela soit le cas mais cela s'est
volatilisé entre de nombreuses mains de
l'équipe mcafee vous n'êtes pas obligés
de me croire aimer actifs restants ont
tous été saisis mes amis se sont
évaporés par peur d'être mise en cause
je n'ai rien cependant je ne regrette
rien réputé iconoclaste john mack et
fille menait une vie rocambolesque
il a ainsi fait parler de lui en 2012
lorsque son voisin au belize petit pays
d'amérique centrale avaient été
assassinés mentionné dans cette affaire
le domicile du gourou de la crypto
monnaie avait été perquisitionné la
policiers avaient alors découvert qu'il
vivait avec une jeune fille de 17 ans et
détenaient plusieurs armes
john mackenzie était ensuite parti en
cavale en 2015 il a été arrêté aux états
unis pour conduite sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants puis en janvier 2019 il a
annoncé sa volonté de briguer la
présidence américaine
pour expliquer son décès
les autorités espagnoles privilégie la
thèse du suicide
l'homme était âgé de 75 ans et risquer
de se voir infliger une peine allant
jusqu'à 30 ans d'emprisonnement et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes avec pierre qui sévit hivernaux
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi sans